of professors from wilford laurier to
talk about the lindsay shepherd scandal
and what happened with professor
rambuchana and pimlott and administrator
adria joel adria right adria joel who i
think is the unsung
what would you call it the unsung
villain in this entire process because
she seems to have escaped relatively
unscathed even though i think her role
is more reprehensible than anyone else's
anyways why don't you guys introduce
yourself and talk about what you've been
doing at wilford laurie and also just
let everybody know
why we're meeting yeah well uh i'm dave
haskell and uh i'm a prophet laurie i am
in the faculty of liberal arts uh this
is my colleague will will how did we
come into this whole thing like this is
this didn't just happen with the lindsay
affair like well to background we
support maximum freedom of expression
and we've really found each other uh
along with a few other professors who
feel the same way that we do that free
expression and free inquiry is the core
value of a university and but
sort of how do we
run into each other business school uh
so my exposure to faculty arts is
minimal and i've been really sheltered
from this professionally
but watching what's happening in the u.s
watching what was happening to you at u
of t i'm a grad i did my phd here
and um
it was in january that uh our
university leadership sent out an email
um explaining to the faculty how to
think about the trump travel ban
and declaring uh its its commitment to
diversity equity and uh inclusivity and
i was really offended by that that they
would uh see fit to pronounce on a
political issue in another country
uh
offended why
i i'm i've got a phd i'm able to reach
my own conclusions about whether these
things are good or bad
i don't need my administration preaching
to me about the right way to think about
an issue a political issue particularly
and so why do you think they did that
and what do you think they were thinking
when they did that because that sort of
seems self-evident right it's not the
administration's role to dictate a
political stance to the faculty that's
just clearly not their role
so what do you think they were thinking
it would it seemed like a manifestation
of trump derangement syndrome it seemed
like just the the same reaction that the
the democrats in the us were having that
they lost to this horrible person and
they couldn't understand why and he was
so reprehensible and here was yet
another terrible thing that he was doing
and we must all agree how bad it was
well i mean even if the funny thing is
even if you can make that case and say
personally and even socially the idea
that you could make that case and then
be university administration and then
tell your faculty to think that way i
mean that's taking it in a whole
different that's taking it to a whole
whole different level of presump
presumptuousness did that come from uh
our administration from the diversity
and equity from the administration from
the leadership the university leadership
is that right the cpam i remember the
it's confusing because i remember we
also got an email from the diversity and
equity office when when trump
won
and they said that they've created a
safe space and they were going to be
open for extra hours in case anybody
needed to go and find uh comfort right
that happened a lot in the united states
hey but you think at least the americans
have some justification for it given
that it's their country i mean we need
safe spaces because a conservative was
elected in the united states in the in
not even in our country it does seem to
be a little bit on the absurd side well
it just to me you know they didn't send
out an email when justin trudeau won and
i have to imagine that there were some
students who were offended like there's
got to be conservative students at
laurier but it's it's very much a
one-sided conversation when we talk
about administration when we talk about
the diversity and equity office they
talk about diversity but they really
don't mean it because they do not want
those students who are ideologically
diverse they talk about inclusion but
they purposely will exclude those
students and an email like that is proof
positive of that kind of exclusion but
what we did so well that was that was
the thing that just got me hopping mad
and i was emailing back and forth with a
colleague of queens uh and we were
talking about the importance of free
speech and this had outraged me and uh
and he sent me a link to a star article
that david had written this is now maybe
a month later in february or march about
uh this guest speaker oh daniel
robitaille yeah yeah yeah and that she
couldn't speak and was she was she uh
gimeshi's lawyer yeah yeah yeah yeah so
merely because she served as a defense
lawyer for someone she was
pilloried well this was another like
when people look at the lindsay shepard
affair
this is not an isolated case at wilford
laurier
this is something that is
it is a regular occurrence and now it
isn't always as high profile but whether
it's students in my office saying
i can't speak
whether it's my colleague sometimes
saying to their students who believes
that they're stifled and every hand goes
up and there have been cases of that
colleagues have come and told me but
we've got these other examples like when
daniel robitaille came to speak at the
brantford campus of wilford laurier and
some students agitated until she was
forced not to do so
and and my my president right we should
provide some background so that was the
ghameshi case right and so gimeshi was a
cbc journalist who was accused of sexual
assault and sexual misbehavior by a
number of people who was immediately let
go at cbc who was dragged viciously
through the press i would say and then
was um
found innocent
in the courts and and but and he had a
defense lawyer and the defense lawyer
had been invited to speak yes she was
part of the defense team she was going
to speak and she wasn't going to speak
about the gomeshi trial in fact she was
going to talk about what it's like to be
a high power powerful lawyer um in in
the big city in toronto and i mean that
would have been really valuable for the
criminology students
but the
students who were agitating against her
really
with the support of several professors
uh they were saying well no if she comes
on it will trigger students it will um
it will mentally harm students
and so that was used as justification
for the interesting too to me to see
that these claims of harm and so forth
are generally put forth by people who
have no clinical expertise whatsoever
and their idea is that the way that you
first of all that the way to aid
people's mental health is to protect
them and there's no evidence for that
whatsoever and the second is that
in your attempts to protect them the
best thing to do is to shelter them from
exposure to ideas that would be
challenging or frightening which is
precisely the opposite of what a
clinician does when he's trying to or
she is trying to
deal with someone who has excess anxiety
what you do
in a case where someone who has excess
anxiety even as a consequence of a
trauma let's say
is you get them to voluntarily expose
themselves to increasingly larger doses
of exactly what frightens them that's
the curative route so not only is it
advice that's being
disseminated say by people who aren't
clinicians it's actually advice that's
being disseminated who are promoting the
opposite of what an informed clinician
would do and it isn't that isn't my
opinion that's that that's as close to a
consensus as anything you could reach
among clinical practitioners right one
the rules for clinical improvement is
get your story straight something like
that talk about your past sort out and
expose yourself to the things that
you're afraid of that you're inclined to
avoid that's the pathway to
to
resilience and more robust mental health
okay so tell us the story a bit you guys
have an inside view of what's happened
on the wilford laurier campus since the
the lindsay shepherd affair broke i
should just say that you know after this
rubber tie event i read david's piece
and immediately emailed him and just
said and that's how we kindred
and uh we met and we had lunch uh and uh
and and just talked about the you know
free speech and the chicago statement
and how can we get it implemented at the
university but we just couldn't see any
way forward and really right so that's
another thing we want to discuss you
guys have rewritten the chicago
statement right so that it's more
appropriate in a canadian context right
we call the laurier free
laurier statement for freedom of
expression okay okay and you've been
trying to convince or
or you're trying to be true you've been
trying to communicate with the
university authorities to have that
ratified essentially adopted as a
statement of principles and have you had
any success with that or what's the
consequence they deferred to a task
force that's that's uh going to be held
uh and we can certainly okay is that in
the aftermath of the shepherd affair is
that going to be part of it really do
anything over the summer just because it
it just seemed
too big a mountain uh and there seemed
to be no way to introduce the idea right
catalyst for it now you've got your
catalyst and lindsay shepherd becomes
the catalyst
and and
you know what
what uh
object lesson in what goes on at laurier
but also
what an object lesson and how you handle
these
free speech opponents
uh she's really
given a model that other students i hope
will follow but it was it was through
this robotic thing that we got to know
each other and a few others yeah there's
a couple more of you that's right yeah
and and so about five i think you told
me that's right so so the robitaille
incident really
brought us out of the woodwork we
started to chat and say you know we see
this problem on our university we don't
know what to do and then when the
lindsay shepherd scandal broke
we all immediately were emailing us
it's happened again is essentially what
we were saying we said we've got to do
something about this uh i'd already
the i was out on a on a trip and i came
home and i said to my wife where are the
newspapers this was uh november 12th
when the story broke christie
blatchford's story and i said hey honey
where the newspaper she said i can't let
you see him i said why not she said you
cannot read the papers and of course it
was because christy blatchford's article
was in there so as soon as i read it i i
was beside myself i thought it's
happened again and this time this is
really terrible they've attacked a ta is
what they've done
so i contacted with the full force of
the administration right and and claims
that she had done mental harm
broken two laws two laws federal and
provincial was
sincerely worried that they were going
to railroad this young lady
oh they could have easily taken her to
the ontario human rights commission they
would have had it what was going to
happen uh i contacted christie blattford
i said can you put me in touch with her
she was kind enough to do so i got in
touch with lindsay and i said
i know that this is a terrible time but
you've got a professor who supports you
i knew that these gentlemen also would
uh and then quickly i as quickly as i
could i wrote an op-ed for the toronto
star that week just again saying this is
happening the world needs to be aware of
it but it was really after that uh that
monday after the story broke on the
saturday we started to talk and and how
can we how can we assist lindsay and and
how can we well the op-ed helped
you and the fact that the star ran it
was quite remarkable as well so hooray
to the star the star really does
want to do its best to champion free
expression yeah well you'd think
journalists would actually be concerned
about that to some degree well and i
think they are like one of the things
that's happened to me in the last year
is that although the press coverage of
what i did and just to remind people so
last year i made a video about bill c-16
which was the bill whose provisions
lindsay shepard theoretically
transgressed against just to be clear
about that and when i first made the
video i was accused by all sorts of
people including journalists of um
well first of all making unnecessary
noise and being unnecessarily alarmist
which were the minor accusations and
then the more major accusations were
that you know i was all the things that
you'd expect a far-right
agitator to be a bigot and a transphobia
and a racist and all of these things and
so but what was interesting was that the
journalists by and large especially the
main journalists turned around on that
issue really quickly it was probably
within three weeks because what happened
was a couple of them actually went and
read the policy documents that i had
referred to on the ontario human rights
commission website which are still there
and which are still appalling and have
led exactly to this situation with
lindsay and as soon as they read what i
had
been
uh
what what outing let's say in my video
then they started to understand that
this what that i wasn't just ringing a
bell for no reason at all it was
actually reasonable i think of people to
go after me to begin with because canada
is such a safe and peaceful place and
our political situation and economic
situation has been so stable that when
someone comes out and says look we're in
danger of making a major error the
logical first response should be
no there's something wrong with you it's
like we're fine there's something wrong
with you
right exactly well and and so it's
reasonable i think it was reasonable for
me to be hit hard in the aftermath of
doing that because
well
generally speaking whistleblowers in
canada or alarmists in canada have very
little to be alarmist about
but this this okay so now so fine so
this thing happened with lindsay what
what have you seen happening on the
wilford laurier campus
things that i'm not particularly proud
of i i would say i mean i knew that uh
will and some other colleagues were
going to come to the aid of lindsay but
i was thinking that once her recording
became public that we would just have a
flood of professors coming to support
our cause which is we had a laurier
statement for freedom of expression
modeled on the chicago state we thought
that immediately people would just say
of course we need to reinforce that this
needs to be the primary mission free
expression free inquiry needs to be the
primary mission and we got that out
pretty fast we really did in about 10
days
uh and and and got it on change.org and
then where i was emailing everybody that
i knew
and trying to get people interested and
i would say out of 50 emails i sent i
got 15 signatures from personal
uh relationships
so even with personal relationships you
could only get a 30 hit rate so what do
you think's stopping professors from
signing that say or clambering on board
especially in the aftermath of the
shepherd recording which we should point
out you know this is one of the things
that's very interesting is that
outside
wilfred laurier and perhaps outside
universities that are in the same boat
the
reaction to that
recording was universal right
and national and international and
uniform and the reaction was what the
hell this is scandalous there's nothing
about this that is acceptable right and
so what's what struck me is so
remarkable is that even though there's
been international outrage over this and
and very
and not
and an outrage of a sort that's only
been disputed by a very small number of
people
at least to begin with wilfred laurier
responded on moss let's say as if this
was somehow debatable you know as if
there were two sides of the story here
let's say and i thought
well i thought rambuchana and pimlot who
were the professors did what they did i
thought was appalling
for in upgrading her and in the manner
in which they did it and in the language
that they used but i thought what was
truly terrifying was the presence of
adria joel at that inquisition because
she was a administrator who was hired
specifically to do exactly what she was
doing by
legislated necessity on the part of the
ontario liberal government right because
it wasn't just the university that was
involved in this her position was set up
because of legislative necessity which
is something also to keep in mind when
we're going after the universities okay
so you had a hard time getting faculty
on board how many faculty members did
sign it 59 is it out of out of how many
faculty
550 full-time and now and so you say
well what what's going on with them well
i think that some
maybe
i know this is hard to believe but maybe
unaware even now
i think there's a big proportion that
are unaware
unbelievable is that it is i think
that's okay well that's its own mystery
because i i don't know where you'd have
to have been in the now last month to
not have noticed that this has happened
the people perhaps in the sciences the
computer sciences the math they they've
got their head down and they're they're
doing their research and and so and so i
don't think there's anything diabolical
there i think that what
as well i've got very few signatures
from the the business faculty i meet
some
but uh a lot of people just aren't
engaged it's a bit of a commuter school
a little bit so i think people are just
getting on with their research and their
teaching maybe not aware of the public
well that's that's an interesting thing
in and of itself because i think part of
what's led
to the occupation of the university
let's say by the radical postmodern
types is the proclivity of the
scientists in particular but also i
would say the more serious scholars to
be focusing narrowly on their field of
inquiry which is essentially what they
should be doing and not paying attention
to any of the broader contextual issues
which is actually a perfectly fine
strategy when things are going well but
a terrible strategy when they're not
and what you also see so we've got these
people who might not be aware
and we've got the the few who are aware
and are supporting maximum free
expression but then you've got these
other people who are convinced that
maximum free expression free inquiry is
not a good thing for a university
and and those people are definitely
congregated within the arts and the
humanities and they justify it because
they are applying a social justice lens
or what they would call a critical
theory lens to this entire uh
this entire issue
and and how about a quick summary of
critical theory well critical theory i
mean in a nutshell it's an idea that
came from the frankfurt school in
germany it transfers over to columbia
university uh it is some german scholars
who are marxist and what they are saying
is that
marxism as an economic unit or as an
economic philosophy really doesn't
work it doesn't transfer very well but
let's change it over to a social theory
and it's a it's a theory of oppressor
and oppressed and it's very bifurcated
you've you are either one or the other
and if you are the oppressed you're good
and if you're the oppressor you're bad
and it's as simple as that there's no
nuance or okay i'm i'm being as bad as
they are to
so i'm giving you the really broad
strokes on this but essentially it does
set up the villain and the victim
and and it is the idea that we must do
everything to silence the villain
the oppressor and to center the to the
oppressed yes and then we will elevate
the oppressed
and the same thing happened essentially
with the french uh deconstructionists in
the 1970s it is so this is this is the
motivation behind it but when when you
hear
um them talk about critical theory
it is not critical thinking there's a
big difference and so parents will hear
well they're teaching critical theory
isn't that a good thing no because
critical thinking means i'm going to
show you both sides of this argument
critical theory means i'm going to
deliberately give you one side of the
argument i'm going to tell you who's
right and i'm going to tell you who's
wrong there's an oppressor and an
oppressed the oppressor is the bad guy
the oppressed is the good guy and it's a
very manipulative way of thinking so uh
so
so there's let's say two reasons why
people wouldn't sign the the the uh the
petition one is they're doing something
else and and they're just not interested
in it and and fair enough even though i
think that that's dangerous at the
moment the second is that they're
actually
philosophically or ideologically opposed
to the propositions and so
to what degree do you think the latter
is the determining factor behind the
relatively small degree of support that
you that you guys have been able to draw
it's a big thing that the uh a group of
faculty signed an open letter uh to the
university complaining about the
violence yeah uh and and that the the
administration need to make the campus
safe safe yeah they did the same thing
with me after i i made my video i was i
made the campus unsafe and 200 people
signed up
signed a petition what does unsafe mean
i mean this is the problem
the the left the far left are taking
words that have a traditional meaning a
traditional definition and they're
blowing that definition completely
completely away and at one time harm
meant that there was an infliction of
damage that would have lasting effect
and it would compromise the appearance
or the function right we can think about
damage to a car right lasting and it's
affecting the appearance or the function
that's what harm is but they've
stretched that definition so that it
becomes meaningless that my an
objectionable idea becomes harm
that that when you show a video you've
made a place unsafe
and
that yeah that's the language of trigger
warnings and safe spaces but but it's
disingenuous there was a trans rally and
one of the speakers said that letting i
hope i can quote this privately letting
peterson's views be heard in the
classroom is violence
it is violence yeah right right now
those are certainly
yes you can react with violence yes well
that's often what i think that i've
thought a lot about one of the tenets of
post-modernism
less so i would say of critical theory
but particularly of post-modernism and
it's more marxist variants is that
the only motivation for the construction
of hierarchies is power
you think well that's
no
there's lots of reasons for producing
hierarchies right there's hierarchies of
competence there's hierarchies of
interest there's higher hierarchies of
aesthetic quality like there's all sorts
of wherever you can make a qualitative
judgment you make a hierarchy so there's
the idea that power is the only
driving force between behind the
construction of hierarchies is
absolutely
preposterous so you think well why in
the world would anyone make that claim
that it's only power that exists well as
far as i can tell at least one of the
reasons is that it justifies the use of
power now if you have your position
because of power which is basically
tyranny then i'm fully warranted in my
use of power against you that's all
there is so i think it's a great
justification for it okay so how many
people signed the petition
stating that the campus had become
unsafe that was like 79
79 just like that okay so you got more
people signing a petition claiming that
what shepard did made the campus unsafe
than you did getting okay so that's
interesting because one of the things
we're going to address later is the
president's letter
as a consequence of the inquiry into the
lindsay shepherd fair and one of the
things she says um
people who've tried to downplay what
happened at lin's at wilford lori have
said basically
two or three things one is
that
well the shepherd is not to be trusted
and she's really like a uh
a subtle arm of the right wing that's
one one and that she's a reprehensible
character yes yes sir peterson i know
they they directly went after i'm quite
sneaky that way um the second is that
pimlott
rambuchana and joel misinterpreted bill
c-16 which i think is absolutely
preposterous i think they interpreted
exactly the way that it was written
especially if you consider the
surrounding policies and that's what i
was warning about last september
and the third is
that this was an isolated incident and
doesn't truly reflect the reality either
of wilford laurier or other campuses and
that's stated explicitly in the
president's letter and so that's one of
the things i wanted to discuss because i
don't buy that i think this wasn't an
anomaly this wasn't people stepping out
of line and i think the proof of that is
not what rambu canada did or pym law
because we could say yeah yeah they're
ideologically committed professors and
they
and they're they're not very
professional in their administrative
abilities and they went after a ta
unprofessionally and stupidly
that's bad
that's not really bad what's really bad
was that there was a paid administrator
at the meeting who was hired to do
exactly that and so the fact that she
was there is the proof to me that this
is not only not an isolated incident
it's actually a logical
concept and a logical and inevitable
consequence of legislative moves that
made these bureaucratic positions
necessary and the practical reality that
these administrative positions do exist
on the campuses so there's no isolated
incident issue there now how do you
think lindsay's been treated at wilford
laurier like
what's your what's your impression of
her of her personal situation there
i think that so on the positive side
there have been students who have
rallied to her support
and that's been really encouraging to
see uh it was
some students on campus who are
dedicated to freedom of expression they
mostly are coming from the the
conservative
clubs whether it's the conservative
political club or other conservative
groups
although
definitely invitations have been
extended to other
groups of other political stripes or
other they really haven't rallied to
lindsay sadly
so those students have
to a certain extent
befriended her or brought her under the
wing or just have begun associating with
her and saying how can we support you i
think in her classes
and i'm just going from what i've seen i
i follow her on twitter so i see what's
been going on there
apparently you know and i don't think
this is inaccurate
the other grad students are being quite
scathing yeah yeah that's that's what
i've heard from her and from her tweets
is that at least they're cold at minimum
they're cold and the professors as well
including the one who told her that she
couldn't use her laptop in class because
she didn't want to be recorded i mean
you couldn't script this level of idiocy
but my my thought is students always ask
me uh dr haskell can i record the what
you're talking about i say yes yes the
answer is yes the answer is yes because
you know what i don't say anything in my
class that i wouldn't publicly say
because i and i want to be accountable i
want people to know what i'm saying in
my class i want them to know i'm fair
i'm balanced i present both sides of the
argument i'm not afraid of that
i mean
why are people afraid of accountability
that that's beyond my understanding yeah
well that's that's a very good that's a
very good question
so okay so um
i think
i think what we'll do now is go through
this letter because what happened
yesterday i guess is the president had
appointed a third-party fact-finder to
look into what happened with the lindsay
shepard affair right and there were
concerns about that because
many people including christy blatchford
were concerned and the lawyer that's
representing lindsay howard um
levitt howard levitt was concerned that
the person who was appointed to do the
third party investigation wouldn't be
neutral because he had tweeted his
agreement with a variety of let's call
them politically correct issues quite
publicly but it does look like he's done
a credible job that that's how it
appears to me anyways the president who
is very
closed-mouthed or
assiduously neutral about this whole
affair has released a report and i
thought we could go through it and talk
about whether or not we think that it
addressed the issues reasonably so
because i think it did in some part but
i think it didn't in others so
this is from um mcclatchy deborah
mcclatchy phd who's the president and
new and vice chancellor at wilford lurie
and relatively new at it so i mean she's
really being raped through the calls
that's for sure but she was the vice
president academic which is the second
most senior position for the last five
years so she's not so she's accustomed
to this okay
okay it is
i believe it is time for some clarity
around the events of the past few weeks
here at wilford laurier university
stemming from the very regrettable
meeting so that's an interesting turn of
phrase to begin with that followed the
showing of a tvo clip by a teaching
assistant during a tutorial as the newly
appointed president and vice chancellor
of this incredible 106 year old
institution i'm here to set the record
straight and announce some important
changes the issue has highlighted some
deficiencies but but as importantly it
has created opportunities
yeah well to me that's a that's a kind
of marketing double speak it's like we
could just go with the deficiencies
issue for now
opportunities for laurier to improve our
own performance to lead a broader
discussion on academic freedom and
freedom of expression
and opportunities to work together as a
community to demonstrate the strengths
we have as an institution
when the issue first broke i erred on
the side of caution as a person and as a
president of as the president of laurier
i'm sensitive to the viewpoints and
concerns of our students staff and
faculty as an employer i am cognizant
that the four people who are in that
meeting room are employees and one is
also a student all four are entitled to
due process i did not want to rush
judgment rather i wanted to ensure we
were able to objectively assess the
facts and make sound def decisions
flowing from that assessment that seems
reasonable enough i would say the events
that have transpired probably justified
her approach
although i had taken issues with some of
the things that she had said and not
said when she was on the agenda but
whatever
we hired an external fact finder with
expertise in human resources issues i've
received the report and we are taking
decisive action to ensure these events
will not be repeated the report along
with what we already knew has led me to
the final conclusions following
conclusions and actions
there were numerous errors in judgment
made in the handling of the meeting with
ms lindsay shepard the ta of the
tutorial in question in fact the meeting
never should have happened at all okay
that's probably the most damning
statement in the entire report i would
say because she and then she says no
formal complaint nor informal concern
relative to a laurier policy was
registered about the screening of the
video this was confirmed in the
fact-finding report okay so we could
take that apart a little bit
no formal complaint okay so
rambuchana claimed that
one or more students had complained he
wouldn't say how many and he wouldn't
say what the nature of the complaint was
now what this document seems to indicate
that
is that well
if there was a complaint which it leaves
vague there was nothing that would
constitute a genuine complaint in an
administrative sense and that's why the
meeting should have never happened so i
guess one question would be
um what if any appropriate disciplinary
action should be taken against
rambuccana and pimlot and i don't know
the answer to that because you know
they're not administrative experts and i
don't think faculty can be but
by the same token
i don't
feel like i understand
exactly what happened to bring about the
meeting to begin with do you guys know
i mean whatever we do know we've had to
piece together
from different media reports because as
has been said uh our president is not
releasing the findings of this
like this is this is going to be this is
a secret the independent investigation
we will never know what it actually says
we don't know what all the
recommendations are we i think we can
take her at her word that she's telling
us what's going on why is she making it
secret or keeping it secret is that is
that
this concern with what do you call it
confidentiality that seems to be the the
what the the camouflage behind which
these things are always hidden that
seems to be implied and or even said
explicitly but i've seen other cases
where there's been disciplinary measures
and and
we we get more details than this
right so so i don't know i don't know
the level of confidentiality that is
required under law but what i can say
and i'll let will talk about what the
disciplinary actions can be let's keep
in mind that when rambuchana said that
there had been a complaint
and it says here that there wasn't
he then echoes that in his apology
to lindsay
he then says of course and i'm i'm
paraphrasing here so i'm not being
completely accurate in terms of what he
exactly said but he said something like
of course there are things i can't
discuss because of the complaint that
was made by a student right so he's
echoing what seems to be an untruth yes
and well this is about as close a
statement as you might imagine in a
statement like this stating that it was
an untruth i mean he said she said
no formal complaint nor informal concern
relative to a laurier policy was
registered i mean that's
that's
that's as close as you can get to coming
right out and saying that the statement
that there was a complaint was a
falsehood and i just want to follow that
thread for a second
so here we have a controversy that was
started
on an untruth
and it seems to be that this is part of
the whole
modus operandi here when we hear and
there's been harm
right and it's unsafe right violence
daily violence although again when the
media global national news globe and
mail checked in to see if there were any
police reports
related to any harassment or any threats
no police reports
so so at some point don't we have to say
there's a boy who cried wolf
well this is even this is more egregious
even though than claiming harm i mean
because you know maybe people were
getting nasty tweets and so forth and i
suspect they were um but
the thing is is that rambuchana and
pimlot directly claimed that there had
been a complaint right and so that's a
big problem that isn't thoroughly
addressed here well and
either somebody uh heard about the
tutorial and the fact that a peterson
video was shown
uh and uh or rambuccana found out
somehow but he decided that was
unacceptable
and that the right way to approach it
was to claim that a student had
complained because it's not a problem
that he found it it's not such a big
problem that he found it unacceptable
let's say it is his class like he has a
right to talk to his ta about what's
going to be shown and what's not going
to be shown even though he handled it i
think reprehensibly in that meeting but
he could come out and say look like that
isn't what the sort of thing i want to
be discussed in my class i don't agree
with peterson i think he's a jerk and
like here's the other things you should
be concentrating on but to come out and
say
a student complained and then to
buttress that with the accusation that
she had violated federal and provincial
law as well as the universe to bring in
adrian joel exactly and i don't
understand why joel was there without
some sort of formal paperwork or
uh evidence of a of a complaint well i i
think that the the
the reason for that is that the
positions that people like jewel occupy
are so ill-defined and so fundamentally
reprehensible in their organization in
their in their aims is that this is
exactly the sort of thing that you would
expect and so i thought she didn't say
much in that
little inquisitorial recording but i
thought the things she did say were
spectacularly um
concerning let's put it that way so what
is what's the discipline what what is
the discipline do you have any sense of
this
like i i can't speculate i don't know
communications or well what i don't what
happens when somebody lies or when
somebody
brings you know forth a complaint that
wasn't a complaint well that is that
well that's one of the things this
document does not address like it's a
big problem it's a big problem
if there was no complaint and the reason
she was disciplined was because there
were because there was a claim that
there was a complaint like that's
well we can we we don't have to be
there's a claim that there's harm what
about if there's a claim that the campus
has daily violence what if there's a
claim that
such and such area has become unsafe
does that need to be
proven or should we be seeking
disciplinary action against people who
are making those claims well that's
that's a very good that's a very good
question okay so so that's that's a
that's a problem that isn't addressed in
this report it's a big one okay and and
i mean the president is obviously not
happy with this because she also says
um
the errors in judgment
okay no formal complaint no informal
concern was registered about the
screening of the video this was
confirmed in the fact-finding report so
they're not beating around the bush
about this they're stating it very
clearly the errors in judgment
were compounded by misapplication of
existing university policies and
procedures basic guidelines basic
guidelines and best practices on how to
appropriately execute the roles and
responsibilities of staff and faculty
were ignored
not just not understood
ignored or not understood okay that's a
pretty damn damning statement there too
so i i don't even know all the
particulars here i heard howard levitt
say that she was entitled to some sort
of represent lindsay was entitled to
some representation under the bylaws of
our university she was supposed to have
had that and that nobody offered that
right so that's an administrative
follow-up at the level of employee
employer relationships to say nothing of
the academic issues at stake so we don't
have policies and procedures about how
to carry out an inquisition
that's not what she's saying
i think there's a medieval document that
you can
use
but but one thing jordan i want to point
out here is that the errors in judgment
were compounded by misapplication of
existing university policies
misapplication of existing university
policies at the end of this document
she's going to say that our gendered and
sexual violence policy needs to be
reviewed
so which is it
was right was it an error an application
or an error in policy and and that's
this is confusing yeah it is because my
suggestion would be the policy is
terribly flawed we have a colleague
who's one of the free speech proponents
at our university dr andrew robinson he
is an expert in human rights law and he
went through our gendered and sexual
violence policy with a fine-tooth comb
and he says this document
is unworkable it makes thought a crime
and and he wrote an op-ed to that effect
so
my point would be and what and who did
he what organization is he part of
yeah but which which sub which which uh
human rights and human diversity right i
mean this is that's exactly it this is
his field yes exactly and so when he
looked at this he says this goes beyond
what the ontario government was even
asking for and it gets to the point
where it actually makes
you can be guilty of
thought crime you can be guilty of
transphobia
without any intent okay well that's the
same in the interim if someone if
someone says i've been harmed mentally
that is enough for conviction under this
particular policy it's the same with the
ontario human rights commission's
policies intent doesn't matter so this
isn't misapplication i'm saying did
adria joelle actually
get it right
and so is it a misapplication or do we
so it'll be interesting if the
university does discipline her
if she gets legal representation who
claims that she was actually applying
the policies correctly because that is
the question right so or but it could be
two things it could be the policies are
flawed and this is the consequence and
they were misapplied we don't know but
there's definitely ambiguity here and
that and that's a crucial issue i think
lindsay was guilty under the gendered
sexual violence policy and she was
adrian was right and accusing her she
was wrong about c-16 uh it would have
been an ontario human rights
uh code violation but
gsb she was right if there had been a
complaint right right this is the right
point okay okay and how many angels can
dance right okay procedures
in how to apply university policies same
issue here and under what circumstances
were not followed the training of key
individuals to meet the expectations of
the university and addressing such an
issue as an issue such as this was not
sufficient and must be improved
okay the question is
who are these key individuals do they
mean rambikana pimlot and joel is that
are they putting all three of those in
there and then the next question would
be
how are they going to improve the
training of key individuals because that
actually worries me as a faculty member
right because
whenever the administration decides that
it's going to engage in some additional
training of faculty members then that
raises the hair on the back of my neck
like is this unconscious bias training
is that what they're talking about which
has been well i think
uh
i can't remember i've just read recently
nosak himself who who developed the iat
just published a review paper
stating clearly stating clearly that
attempts to reduce unconscious bias by
explicit explicit training there's no
evidence whatsoever that they have any
positive effect and that was nosek
himself who helped develop the iat
because the little coterie that
developed that test
the chair of the harvard psychology
department i'll remember her name in a
minute green walled anthony greenwald
and nozek what's her name mazarine
banerjee three of them developed it
they're starting to fragment a bit
because the thing has been pushed way
too hard right it's not a test that's
valid for the purposes that it's being
put to and they know it perfectly well
even though they're consulting about it
and have made quite an enterprise out of
it but nozek is you know who seems to be
a pretty credible scientist and he's
actually looking at the data and it's
clear that the these unconscious bias
training programs have
zero positive impact there's some
evidence that they have negative impact
because of course people don't like
being accused of being unconscious
racists right so i'm wondering is that
the kind of training
and there's nothing in here that says
this but this is the problem that it
says there will be training
unconscious by is that the same as
systemic discrimination well it's the
it's the neurological equivalent of
systemic discrimination so imagine
systemic discrimination is built into
the structure of the system right
unconscious bias is built into your
perceptual structures so even before you
act or think you're biased towards
against the members of an out group
that's the claim and not only biased in
against the members of out group which
is a different claim that biased in
favor of your in-group which of course
almost every human being is especially
if you think about your family but that
that that implicit bias also manifests
itself in behaviors that would
essentially be categorizable as
racist at least at a low level and
there's very little evidence that the
implicit bias that this test
hypothetically measures
manifests itself in measurable behavior
so
we went through a thing in the summer
where
they ran a regression on salaries at
laurier and found that uh
women were paid a little bit less than
men by about four percent and so they
gave all the did they include eight did
they include age as a covariate uh
the answer to that would be no
the model was uh it had um
rank
uh and i don't know that it had eight it
only had four categories of professor
though
when this has been done at university of
michigan for instance because i looked
at comparables they had 21 categories of
professor
uh or 21
departments
and at ours we had four so you were
comparing people for instance within the
business school who might be in
marketing versus someone who psychology
yeah well i know i know from setting up
regression equations ad nauseam that the
the covariates that you include in the
equation determine the outcome of the of
the of the equation well the conclusion
they reached the explanation for the the
statistical significance of the gender
coefficient was systemic discrimination
right right of course well that that
wasn't the conclusion they reached that
was the conclusion they stepped into the
inquiry with and they gerrymandered the
statistics until they found a regression
equation that supported their their
initial claim
so that was that's not an inquiry but so
there's what i hear you're saying is
there's really no scientific basis for
this idea that there could be this
unconscious bias that could drive
there is evidence that we're full of
unconscious biases i mean we couldn't
even see if we didn't have unconscious
biases because we have to use shortcuts
and heuristics to just process the world
the issue is
what
measurable impact does that have on
behavioral that's the first thing and
it's minimal at best first of all it's
not easy to distinguish between racial
bias and novelty avoidance
right because what you'd have to do is
you'd have to find a person in a racial
group say a white person who was just as
familiar with black people as with white
people and then show that there was a
bias because otherwise you can't
distinguish it from a novelty novelty
aversion and people are characterized by
novelty aversion you already have
developed a preference for that cup over
this cup i mean it happens that quickly
and it's that it's that subtle and and
great and grand let's say so the first
issue is we can't really distinguish
unconscious bias from perceptual habit
let's say or from or stereotyping from
categorization for that matter and that
literature has been under assault in a
major way in the social psychology
literature but even assuming that an
implicit bias does exist which you might
there might be grounds for by noting
that people do have an in-group
preference say for their family members
and perhaps even for their racial
members although it's hard to
distinguish that from novelty or from
familiarity preference
putting all that aside
which you can't
there's no evidence that these courses
that are put in place to reduce that
bias have any effect whatsoever on the
bias it's complete even the people who
are pushing the iat and the idea of
implicit bias are willing to say well
all these things that we're doing to try
to reduce it have absolutely no effect
or if anything a negative effect and
again just we don't know that what the
training is going to be i guess where we
went down this rabbit hole was we don't
know what the training is going to be
right we don't know it's
we have no evidence to assume we have no
reason to assume that the training is
going to address the proper problem and
every reason to be skeptical that it
won't okay so next
um
there is also institutional failure that
allowed this to happen well we don't
know what that means because i'd like to
know what the institutional failure was
but that's a pretty broad and she says
when when there is institutional failure
responsibility ultimately starts and
ends with me well that's a nice
statement and okay she's taking
responsibility for it but unless it's
specified what the institutional
failures are it's just hand waving going
forward we will implement improved
training and new procedures and engage
in a very specific administrative review
details would be nice to strengthen and
enhance confidence in what students and
employees can expect at laurier
specifically there was no wrongdoing on
the part of ms shepard in showing the
clip from tvo in her tutorial
showing a tvo clip for the purposes of
an academic discussion is a reasonable
classroom teaching tool well thank god
for that given that tvo is a publicly
funded uh
middle-of-the-road left-leaning liberal
news media establishment a credible one
for sure i wish that
early on
immediately following this story
breaking
that
administration had said exactly that
because remember for more than a month
now
the public the canadian public has
wondered can you show
tv ontario videos in classrooms at
laurier right
and i'm not i'm not joking yeah like
this was right well this is the question
and and there has not been an answer
from administration on that very basic
question
and so people who are thinking about
sending their kids to laurier
are thinking is that the place where
they didn't know
whether or not you could show public
television in a classroom
is that the place where it took a
independent investigation
to come to the conclusion that it's okay
to play a clip from the agenda
that
well we still don't yes exactly it is
the place where all of that was in doubt
that is wilfred laurie it is the place
where those things were in doubt and so
they're not quite as in doubt but we
also still don't know what else is
what else is still in doubt right
because if that can be you wonder well
you know that's pretty damn innocuous
okay any instructional material needs to
be grounded in the appropriate academic
underpinnings to put it in context for
the relevance of the learning outcomes
of the course
yeah well the question there is any
instructional material needs to be
grounded in the appropriate academic
underpinnings to put it in context the
question there is who decides
what the appropriate academic
underpinnings to put it in context are
because that's supposed to be the that's
supposed to be the bailiwick of the
professor period right and with with
some leeway for the for the teaching
assistants and so on
but i worry when i hear about context
because i've seen opinion pieces from
some of my colleagues who tell me that
the appropriate context is within the
frame of social justice or within the
frame of critical theory
well that's what rambuccano said to
shepherd was that well part of the
reason you were wrong was because you
portrayed it neutrally if you had
contextualized it essentially if you
would contextualize peterson as hitler
which was rambakana's statement then it
would have been perhaps appropriate to
to to air the video and that is
equivalent to leading the witness right
and leading the witnesses when we have a
lawyer an authority figure telling the
person on the stand what to say taking
my ideas and putting them into that
person's mouth right well that's how you
produce unconscious bias
but but my point would be so i'm not
saying that this is in here
but we really need clarify yeah well
that's that's a that's a sentence that
doesn't that i'm not happy about
appropriate academic underpinnings to
put it in context for the relevance of
the learning outcomes of the course
jesus it's just
administrative double speak the whole
way through
you present in class you know what are
the criteria for evaluating that i i
show videos all the time in the class
i don't know if they have the adequate
underpinnings
yeah well that's that's the question is
who decides that the the answer to that
there's a simple answer to that the
professor that's the answer there isn't
another answer there's no board there's
no higher authority there's nothing else
you know when i show i do show clips
from hitler in my class in my
personality class when we talk about
orderliness and totalitarianism i show
clips from the triumph of the will and i
show this other documentary called crum
which is about
an underground
cartoonist from the 1960s named robert
crumman it is an absolutely shocking
documentary like if you ever want to
know more than you want to know about
rapists and serial killers that
documentary will tell you it's really
it's a tough it's a tough watch you know
and
i can't
i can't imagine a
like a committee reviewing my teaching
materials and
allowing those things to go forward
without challenge be a disaster okay the
ensuing discussion also needs to be
handled properly
yeah well
we have no reason to believe this
discussion was not handled well in the
tutorial in question okay so whatever
handled property means lindsay shepard
managed it which i think is a good sign
here because if we take that as the
model lindsay did present the
information neutrally and and she was
not taking sides and if that's our model
that's that's a good sign okay that's
good so that's acceptable so i'm a bit
troubled by this because we're gonna in
three or four paragraphs find out that
we need enhanced training for tas right
so did she handle it properly right why
do we need to treat the training yes
that's right and again who's going to do
the training because it's not going to
be the faculty because the faculty don't
have time or the inclination for that
matter to run that kind of training is
it going to be the diversity in equity
yeah right well that's the question
who's going to do the training i have
apologized to ms shepard publicly as has
dr rambokana her supervising professor
the university has conveyed to her today
that the results of the fact-finding
report to make the results of the
fact-finding report to make sure she
understands it is clear that she was
involved in no wrongdoing yes well for
someone who was involved in no
wrongdoing she sure bloody well got
raped over the coals for the last month
so
the university is taking concrete steps
to make changes to ensure this doesn't
happen again yeah well good
it has been made clear to those who were
involved in the meeting with ms shepard
that their conduct does not meet the
high standards i set for staff and
faculty well that is a big question
there right how has it been made clear
to those who were involved in the
meeting with ms shepard that their
conduct does not meet those high
standards because we don't know does
that mean did the president talk to them
has there been disciplinary action like
we we because if it was i don't even
know what would be appropriate
but i would say that not
knowing what was done is not appropriate
so
and i think it deserves specifics i mean
that's what got me into this was you the
the christy blatchford's article was was
very accurate because she already had
the audio but then when we heard the
audio it was so appalling what was done
to her in that room it was such
horrible bullying uh and just such a
violation of what the university
should stand for
that's what coalesced all of the anger i
mean in canada yeah the devil's in the
details
so it's the same with the
how it has been made clear to those who
were involved
so because i don't
i mean maybe this is something we could
talk about too i don't know what would
constitute appropriate disciplinary
message measures as a
consequence you have here three people
acting on a non-existent complaint who
produced an international scandal
that damaged lindsay in a real sense
although it might have also made her
stronger but it certainly it certainly
didn't have to because a lesser person
would have crumbled i don't know if she
would feel that she i i think she might
take exception to that uh she certainly
has not claimed any kind of victim
status throughout this whole thing and i
think that's no but that's more a
testament to her character than anything
else because i mean she was subject to
the kind of attacks i would say that
would have snowed under a lesser person
yes but
she has
risen to this challenge yes definitely
definitely well and and thank god for
that but then there has been real harm
done to the university as far as
so and i i don't know how you would
quantify that in financial terms but i
suspect it's substantial but
reputational terms i mean now i would
say internationally this is what wilford
laurie is known for so maybe that's an
overstatement but i don't think so
as these are individual employment
issues i cannot go into greater detail
on any individual case well that could
be but know that the university has and
is taking action to rectify the
situation and send a clear signal that
this cannot and will not happen again
that sounds pretty that's very
forthright yeah it is
one key improvement highlighted is the
need to enhance our faculty and ta
training
yeah
well
like i said as a faculty member whenever
i see that i don't see the role of the
administrators at a university to to
train the faculty that's not their role
their role is to move paper around for
the faculty fundamentally
it is the responsibility of course
instructors to develop guidelines for
the roles and expectations of their tas
fair enough the university also has high
expectations of professors as ta
supervisors we recognize the need to do
more in this area
we reckon uh the university's intent is
to enhance the training and support for
both ta supervisors and teaching
assistants making these mandatory and
standardized
that's my favorite part jesus dismal
so that so my suspicions
as a skeptic are that
the
making of training for faculty
mandatory and standardized will do more
harm
than this scandal has done
over the long run so we don't know what
the training is we don't know who's
going to do it we don't know what it's
going to be about but the one thing we
do know is it will be mandatory yeah
mandatory and standardized right yeah
mandatory and standardized be
interesting to see how they'll do that
too because it isn't so easy to make
training mandatory for faculty members
right you can't just do that by fiat
because they can generally tell you to
go to hell and should
gendered and sexual violence policy
it has become clear to us that managing
the new gendered and sexual violence
policy now that's the one that's
mandated by the provincial government so
it was bill uh 163 the provincial bill
that said you need to have a
policy on gendered and sexual violence
right according to our colleague
dr andrew robinson he says we go way
beyond what the province even asked for
to the point where it becomes
unmanageable and and you have instances
of thought crime so so that's what we
have
like this like this yeah where you can
claim that somebody is transphobic
for simply showing a video can i can i
read you the definition
is this from the genderedness yes it is
this is from our policy this is from our
policy
it is an action that reinforces gender
inequalities resulting in physical
sexual emotional economic or mental harm
okay so what's the first part of that
again yes yeah you get lost don't you
it is an action that reinforces gender
inequality okay so let's start with that
an action
that reinforces gender inequalities okay
so the first thing we might point out is
that no one knows what the hell that
means right it's a box that you can put
anything in so actions
that's a problem
because what it isn't obvious what
constitutes an action or an inaction for
that matter so i mean and
and then that reinforces gender
inequalities
right so that that's that's the sort of
sentence that only someone who's
ideologically possessed to the maximum
would create because you can't parse it
gender inequalities like what does that
mean exactly
i don't i'd well anyway discrimination
on sex or gender it doesn't talk about
discrimination it talks about inequality
right which is which is it would be
different if the the phrasing had
included the words discrimination
okay and the next part is resulting in
physical sexual emotional economic or
mental harm
right right so it says broadly construed
both both clauses are as broadly
construed as they can be
and the reason for that is to allow
maximum scope for interpretation which
is exactly what happened with adrian
joel well mental harm again mental harm
and and as you pointed out
mental harm
is not backed up by the empirical
evidence apart from
uh post-traumatic stress syndrome like
cognitive behavioral therapy would
suggest that you actually can do mental
good
by exposing someone to objectionable
ideas when they've in moderation in
order to help them become less mentally
fragile uh scott lillifeld out of emory
university they're a very credible
scholar
well he is one of the
master he's written several textbooks on
psychopathology right he knows his stuff
and uh just this year he put out a paper
where he explored the the empirical
evidence around microaggressions
and he did all of the literature he and
microaggressions are of course these
innocuous actions that are deemed to be
bigoted or or somehow sexist
it's
essentially well they are actually it's
showing a video
of from tvo is what a microaggression is
and what he said was there is absolutely
no evidence there's no evidence that
microaggressions these objectionable
ideas lead to mental harm he also said
that the the concept itself is
extraordinarily ill-defined which is
also a big problem right that was the
beginning of our conversation everything
is ill-defined yeah while that if you
make the box big enough you can put
anything into it
and what you see
uh in this gender and violence policy
that
will is reading from
they are they're actually go on to say
that um this can include
heterosexism yeah like you can be your
your mental crime could be heterosexism
yeah so what if i said something in
class like the empirical evidence
strongly suggests that raising children
in a two-parent family leads to better
outcomes which it does by the way like
it like and seriously it does so then
well so that's the question
well arguably right arguably i've
transgressed that policy now here's an
interesting thing too so
it has become clear to us that managing
the new gendered and sexual violence
policy has led to a confusion in its
application right okay so this is back
to the issue we described earlier is it
a confu confusion in the application or
in the policy now you just read the damn
policy now it seems to me that there's
no way you could apply that policy
without confusion so it's not a
confusion in its application it's it
might also be that but it's a confusion
in the policy written right into it okay
so that's that's of crucial importance
right in fact the interviews conducted
by the fact finder confirmed that the
rationale for invoking the gsvp did not
exist it was misapplied and was a
significant overreach
yeah
i'm not so sure about that because i
know that these kind of policies emerge
from the same sort of policy framework
that characterizes the ontario human
rights commission it's the same people
doing it and the ontario human rights
commission policies are written so that
they can be
broadly misapplied with no significant
overreach
so
so okay so that's a problem
to provide clarity of the policy's
intent
and to strengthen accountability we will
engage in an administrative review with
the goal of finding the appropriate
structure to oversee and execute the
gsvp and its accompanying procedures we
will also undertake a full review of the
policy and its procedures okay so good
so there they're saying well it might
have been misapplied but maybe the
policy itself also has some problems i
think this is really good news yeah and
we had a a meeting with our colleague
andrew andrew robinson today and we said
well you know what do you think about
this and he was pleased he said you know
if some good has come out of this
controversy this is one of those good
things because
definitely the gendered and sexual
violence policy we have at laurier
isn't workable it is prejudiced against
certain people and and certain ideas and
so it needs to be reworked because at
this it is not an inclusive document it
excludes and so it needs to be fixed so
this is a good thing
well and it's also a canary in the coal
mine for similar policies at
universities all across canada would say
and maybe broader because one one thing
you'd hope is that the lindsay shepard
affair has produced enough
negative repercussions to set people
back on their heels a little bit and
make them dig into these policies
because i can't imagine that there's
another university in canada who would
enjoy partaking in a scandal of
equivalent magnitude
what i would hope and on that point
jordan
if someone is a student or if someone is
a faculty member ask for the evidence
that's what i've learned from this there
are a lot of claims out there
mental harm our campuses become unsafe
uh
the ideas that are contained in the the
gendered and sexual violence policy i'm
saying okay
what is the evidence that proves this
because this is this is what a
university is supposed to be based on
from the enlightenment to today we are
supposed to be able to say here's the
evidence for what why we do this and the
further we get away from evidence and
the more we embrace ideology we
completely remove what the mission of a
university is supposed to be well and
the idea of evidence we remove the idea
of evidence which means we remove the
idea of knowledge because there's no
distinction between knowledge and
evidence right right so so
if you are a student and you want to say
what what can i do say what's the
evidence of mental harm what's the
evidence that that this that i'm
transphobic right well well so partly
what you're also saying there is a
restatement of the old presumption of
innocence idea it's like okay you're
accusing me of something prove it i'm
innocent buddy prove it where's your
evidence yeah i know we do i know well
part of that's tied up with this with
the sexual harassment issue because
increasingly and this is this is this is
started i think most particularly in the
united states we're moving towards a
preponderance of evidence standard
instead of an assumption of innocence
standard that's especially true with
these sexual harassment policies that
are being derived by
derived
from
institutions and administrators
concerned with such things as the
gendered and sexual violence policy and
that that's related to the comment you
made earlier about the lawyer who wasn't
allowed to speak right because she had
the temerity to offer someone who was
accused of a crime a legal defense
when apparently what we were supposed to
do was just assume that the people who
were making the accusations were right
because they claimed that they were
wronged so and and to to be i mean we
always have to do our caveats don't we
we say
i know that we want to protect people
who are victims like i each of us would
agree
but it can't be done at this sacr by
sacrificing truth well you don't protect
people from being victimized by
undermining the rule of law quite the
contrary
because ultimately it comes back to bite
you in the behind yes that's for sure
and very very rapidly so okay in the
interim we will ensure access to the
existing support and complaints
procedures by providing management and
oversight through the office of dispute
resolution and support
okay i'm not sure what that means well
it's actually very good news okay okay
it means that uh
the oversight of this is being removed
from the diversity and equity office and
put under the president's direct control
so she doesn't think that they're
responsible
um
and i'm very worried about diversity and
equity office overreach this suggests
that the president as you should be it
suggests the president is also worried
about the diversity and equity office
that she has said we're not imagine why
but but the fact that she has done this
is really
uh a strong sign that that she is aware
that that office needs to be it needs to
be right or at least that she's
concerned enough about the reputation of
the university so that she's not going
to let the same mistake happen again
which is a good thing like i don't care
why she's doing it particularly but it's
a good thing that it is being done okay
so fine so that's that's that's good
news the this has the added benefit of
improved accountability as that office
reports through to me as president yeah
okay well you can see in those lines
that she's not particularly happy about
what's happened i wonder what sort of
financial hit wilfred laurier took
because you could imagine that while the
donors are going to be a lot more
conservative than the than the
professors and the administrators and
the students well we have uh we've been
contacted by a group of alumni who have
now organized they haven't yet released
what would be their their press release
but slowly they've been reaching out to
other alumni and it's the laurier alumni
for free expression and what they have
said is their mandate is one to withhold
all donations
until laurier accepts the laurier
statement for freedom of expression and
uh
i i haven't checked in it was just
someone acting on her own uh she's a
laureate alumni
she has
i guess contacts within the alumni
association and she just she sent us a
con some contact information and said
here's what i'm doing wanted you to know
i support your efforts and i'm i'm
working on this i'll let you know when
i'm ready to go and so that was really
encouraging i have a colleague who does
a survey of uh chief financial officers
quarterly to gauge their optimism about
the economy and started down at duke and
he's doing it now for canada and he got
responses from two uh he because he sent
out an email just shortly after this
broke he got responses from two alumni
who just said you're you know why should
i participate in this why should i help
you this is not so i don't have any
respect for you these are alumni of of
wilford laurier university yes well and
i can imagine too that enrollment is
going to take a pretty vicious hit you
know our business school is quite
excellent uh we have a great car program
we in the finance area attract a lot of
very strong students and we compete for
top-tier students in ontario the entry
average is like 89 or something and and
we really compete for the what we call
the high flyers and they can choose any
school right in the province right right
yeah well it doesn't take much of a hit
to a reputation to give people who have
options the reason to go elsewhere right
and then you lose the best people and
that's when things really start to fall
apart and what you might begin to see
and i would say that this is something
that the general public might look at
watch what happens to the entrance
averages in the arts and humanities
that so so so we might not take a hit
but let's see if the averages take a hit
of course because suddenly and and
currently the entrance average to get
into our general arts program uh in
communications let's just talk
communications is mid 70s with an
average of 60 in english
so so i i don't i mean right which is
basically a failing grade right because
if you hand in an essay in high school
you'll get 60. you really will right so
it's it's basically the grading
basically runs from 60 it goes zero you
didn't hand it in 60 to 100 you handed
it in and let's keep in mind that the
tutorial that lindsay was running was a
grammar tutorial
the content of which looked a lot like
grade six curriculum yeah yeah well that
gets us into a discussion of the schools
in general but we're already i'm
thinking that maybe it's not a good idea
to lower standards any anymore right
right right okay okay so academic
freedom and freedom of expression
for those who have chosen to use this
incident as an indictment of wilford
laurier university or the plight of
canadian universities in general i say
your assertion is unreasonable and
unfounded well we better stop this
interview yeah yeah well you you can say
that all you want i i would say instead
that what happened at wilford laurier is
a precise manifestation of exactly the
sort of rot that both produced bill c-16
and that i was warning about last
september and so i don't think the
assertion is unreasonable and unfounded
at all and here's one piece of data
eighty percent of humanity's papers are
not cited once
so
so so let's just translate that for the
viewing public yes that means that
they're producing scholarship that
nobody looks at yes that that even their
friends don't look at and and because
okay so what a citation is is i read
someone's paper and i find a good idea
in it and then i use that idea to
buttress an idea of my own or to or to
or to riff off or to or to
or to criticize even for that matter and
then i cite them i say who they were and
when they published it and then the
paper the sign that there's a huge
bureaucracy that keeps track of
citations and it's a major indication of
academic ability to be cited right it's
it's the it's like it's academic payment
to be cited okay so 80 of humanities
papers don't get cited once
it's absolute failure absolute failure
as a game if someone wanted to play a
game
uh i would suggest that they go and they
look at the publications
of the professors in a particular area
and see if the titles all sound the same
and if they all say something about
intersectionality
colonialism
and and these other various uh
social justice words
you might wonder am i going to get
taught the same course again and again
by every professor in this program
because it seems to me that all of their
research is is very similar
uh and and
how can that be when there's such a
broad base of knowledge in the world
that we can have
such similarity between every
publication which then goes on why why
do i need to read my colleague stuff
when it's exactly like my own
which which we see so just just as a
baseline jordan how many
what would you say is is someone who's
doing some good research what's how many
citations would would they be receiving
maybe uh collectively like what are we
looking for thousands thousands yeah
well a good like if you
if you write a good paper
then
like a great papal paper will get you
100 citations right an outstanding
overwhelmingly outstanding paper will
get you a thousand citations
um
10 isn't none you know it you register
with 10
but zero is that's failure right it
means your work had zero impact it it
means your work wasn't worth the paper
it was published on and this this brings
us to a kind of interesting little issue
with regards to the rot in the
universities which which deborah
mcclatchy says does not exist it's like
here's how the game works is that
we set up a little ideological garden
right the ten of us play in and then we
all publish in the same journal and we
peer review each other's articles and we
just publish them there's no critique or
very little so the the
barrier for publication is very very low
when it should be very high like a good
journal a good journal will reject 90 of
the papers that are that are are
submitted to it right so
um
rejection rates really matter
so
the question is why do the these papers
get published since no one reads them
and they have nothing to offer and the
answer to that is very straightforward
the journals are extremely expensive
they're way more expensive than they
should be so just to buy a single paper
online for the ordinary person is like
forty dollars which is more than a
hardcover book that's just to download
the pdf and so the journal itself the
libraries are full of them are very
expensive and the subscriptions are very
expensive and so what happens is the
professors pressure the university
libraries to buy the journals and the
library funds the publisher and so the
publishers will publish anything
routledge is a good example of that much
to my chagrin because they published my
first book but and they used to be a
great publishing house but they'll
publish damn near anything and the
reason for that is that the libraries
are forced to pay radically inflated
prices for the
publications that no one ever reads and
so people write
to publish in journals that libraries
have to purchase at inflated prices
to produce knowledge that no one will
ever read and that's the little scandal
that
plagues the humanities i think it
characterizes the humanities more than
plagues them so the idea that there's no
systemic rot let's say in the
universities especially in the
humanities is just not this is just far
too general um there there is rot and
it's not everywhere and this just
reveals that i don't think she's that
familiar with the situation she's in and
and i've been listening to some of your
work and and jonathan hate trying to
understand what's been going on over the
last two years in universities
protected as i am in a business school
and starting to realize that it's not
everywhere it's it's the social justice
perspective the stem fields are fine so
far right yeah and the business schools
although there there are moves into the
business schools but they're still doing
all right philosophy is not doing too
badly like there are disciplines that
have still remained untouched and mostly
what's happened so far is that if the
discipline has a strong economic or
scientific footing it's proved much
harder to corrupt an empirical yeah
for my part so i play in the playground
of sociology of religion but all my
stuff well most of my stuff is
quantitative so i actually i wasn't
familiar with what was going i don't i
go to conferences where everybody has to
have strong empirical evidence i publish
in journals that are international
journals that are the scientific study
of religion is what what we do so you
know i'm familiar with foucault and and
that stuff but that's not where i play
so i wasn't really exposed to what's
going on and you don't and you don't
really think well
they can't there's no reason to be that
concerned about it until about three
years ago well this is it and but then
i'm trying to get into the headspace
of some of my colleagues so i got out a
textbook it was called race class and
gender and it's it's an anthology that's
used in
cultural studies courses in women's
studies courses and it's sort of the
go-to text so i'm told
and i'm reading it and i turned it and i
i would turn to page 14 and i can tell
you it's page 14 because i was so
astounded by what i found
and it said
uh we the oh it says
objectivity as found through rational
thought
is a western and masculine concept that
we will challenge throughout this text
yeah right
yeah yeah and i said
it's too bad it's too bad that you're
shocked by that
because so you want to go for irrational
the pc types have been saying exactly
that since the 1970s like that is
exactly make no mistake about this this
is why mcclatchy is wrong this isn't
this isn't something they're secreting
in
this is the dead statement oh yeah it's
it's that um
the whole notion of logic and coherence
and empirical data for that matter
evidence
is a very nature evidence
let's question let's question the
definition of evidence because the
underlying idea remember the underlying
idea here is that all hierarchies are
predicated on power so if the reason
that i put forward something as evidence
isn't because it's evidence
it's because it's evidence that i get to
have that position of power and so if
you're a post-modernist and you say well
i'm going to question your evidence what
you think you're saying is you're going
to question my claim to that arbitrary
power the whole idea that there's
evidence outside of claims of arbitrary
power the post-modernist dispensed with
that in the 1970s that's derrida
that's exactly what he said
and all this time i've been trying to
get samples of thousands so that i could
say you know this is a little bit
we can say something god just can
generalize no no that just demonstrates
how thoroughly entrenched you are in the
reigning patriarchal ideology i guess
and i was just hoping to get beyond
anecdotal
there's no beyond acting you there's no
beyond anecdotal that's become a
methodology that's auto experience it's
called autoethnography
there's a technical term for it and
autoethnography is the publication of a
journal of a of a private diary
essentially in a
hypothetically reputable
reputable academic journal just
i it's only because of in the last three
or four years that these things have
been happening and i said well where
where do they get this how do they how
do they
find these thoughts yes well we don't we
don't want to fall into the mistake of
making of making the assumption that
this hasn't been thought through
no people are not just misunderstanding
what evidence is that isn't what's
happening at all when they say they want
to question the definition of evidence
that's exactly what they mean when they
say we want to question the definition
of evidence because the definition of
evidence currently supports the
scientific power structure in chemistry
say and that's fundamentally dominated
by let's say white men we can go after
the definition of evidence itself and
that's how we're going to bring it down
and so the next people on the hit list
are going to be the biologists they're
already under attack from this
paper that said that mathematics is
whiteness yeah yeah yeah
definitely i didn't know that
mathematics could have a race
yeah but the thing the thing is there's
nothing illogical about these claims
once you accept this central axioms the
axioms are straightforward the world is
a battleground of power hierarchies
that's what it is there isn't anything
else outside of that
and each power hierarchy generates its
own internal
narrative
including rules for what constitutes
evidence that support and buttress the
structure of that
hierarchy
and because the hierarchies exclude then
it's in the best interests of the people
who are excluded to invert the hierarchy
and of course they also regard that as
just even though that's
part of the incoherence of the entire
argument that's where they have to turn
to marxism but make no mistake about it
this isn't this isn't accidental it
isn't people misunderstanding what
constitutes evidence
not at all no i've been listening to
some of your lectures on this for the
last year and thinking you sound a
little
deranged
well i i might be a little deranged but
i'm not deranged about this and
and then this whole episode with lindsey
shepherd just just proves it
every dimension of this is about power
uh
the double speak the the changing of
terminology from harm that exposing
people the ideas could be violent uh the
circling the sacred circling around the
victim group
well look at look at what happened at
wilford laurier one of the things that
was so bloody interesting that i thought
was just fascinating was the
unbelievably
strategic attempt to transform shepard
into the perpetrator and rambikana and
pimlot into the victims especially
ramacana as a professor of color right
so so what what happens
the reverse narrative was well lindsay
shepard was using something like her
white privilege and her white tears yeah
to to harass a poor professor of color
untenured professor of color yeah yeah
and that and there was every
attempt made on the part of the people
who were going after shepherd to make
that the narrative
so well and they they started accusing
everyone of of being transphobic just
right out of the blocks within days of
this we were all tired with that epithet
uh immediately the labels have been just
flying and without any regard to the
intent of the person or even the content
here here's something interesting about
the transphobia issue too so i've had at
least
now a number of discussions with trans
people by the way but also a number of
letters from trans people over the last
year about 40 of them as a matter of
fact which is a lot of letters because
there aren't that many trans people and
every single one of them i think i got
one letter from a trans person who
wasn't happy with what i was doing but
every single one of the other letters
said the same thing we are sick and
tired of being the poster child for
these activists who claim to speak in
our name because that's another thing
that we should be very aware of is just
because an activist comes out and says
i'm a member of this minority group and
therefore i speak for them it's like the
first claim might be true but the second
claim is not only unjustifiable it's
actually
i would say it's
it's not racist exactly but it's it's
groupist
because it's predicated on the
assumption that just because you happen
to be the member of a class that you're
a representative member of that class
that class is so homogeneous that
everyone in it is the same enough so
that all the members within it can speak
for all the other members right you used
to call that racism when was it applied
to racial categories absolutely but
lindsay has been very good to point out
and so of some of the media
that there have been
transgendered students at laurier who
have spoken out in support of lindsay
and we have to keep this in mind that
this is not a transgendered issue no and
neither was my comments on bill c-16
because i mean
all
i know
that
lindsay as she even said she is not
transphobic she supports the rights of
transgendered people this is she's
unequivocal in that uh and and i think
that that's just cover story for her
true right-wing beliefs
and there are transgendered students who
have come to her support and at great
personal cost to themselves like those
are some brave people there right to
break with that group that the hostility
in that group is real
in the activist end of the group
you bet
they were so quick uh to take over this
uh issue as their own and claim that the
the debate itself was violence yeah and
that it was just cover for this
transphobic climate uh that existed and
it has nothing to do with transgendered
people well you know it's it's funny too
you saw the same thing with um renaldo
walcott when he was on the director of
the women's and diversities women's and
gender studies at the at oisi at the
university of toronto he claimed that he
claimed like four times in that
interview that the university of toronto
was a white supremacist organization and
i thought i i just don't know what to
make of that like i i traveled down to
my office about a week after that
that
that interview and i happened by some
students who were standing outside
waiting to
write an exam so there's about 100 of
them may and
like this is particularly true at the
university of toronto i would say that
you you could look at that group of
students for more than two seconds and
think that that was a white supremacist
organization i mean it's so ethnically
diverse
if you think that the university of
toronto is a
white supremacist organization
then what that essentially means is that
the most tolerant institution
in the most tolerant city in the most
tolerant province in the most tolerant
country in the world is white
supremacist
so it's like
well then
well
i don't well i don't i don't even know
what you could especially when you say
that as
someone who's a full professor
i don't know if he's a full professor
who's a professor at that institute it's
like where's your evidence for this that
same professor was using racial slurs
against lindsey
oh yes the white tears thing
they're also misogynistic right because
it's white girl tears i could never
ever
do something like that to any student of
any race i just don't understand how the
people on the far left can rationalize
that kind of behavior
it it just it's
well i think they can rationalize it
with power but in terms of civility just
in civility in recognizing the humanity
in every person
how can you resort to those kind of
racial slights i just i don't i don't
understand how you can say don't be
racist and then you make racial comments
terribly racist comments i just i don't
under do people well no there's the idea
there is straightforward
you cannot utter racist comments against
the dominant group
that's the rule
if there's a dominant group so once you
identify them as oppressor you can say
anything you want about them because by
definition this is axiomatic in in the
ideology you can't say anything racist
about the oppressors that that's like a
rule it's it's
it's a rule of discourse so here's where
i go with this for self-interest
do you not realize when you say i don't
care about your effing white fragility
now that was not waldicott is that his
did i get his name right
walcott
walcott he didn't say but others other
pundits have said that and it's appeared
on lindsay's twitter page where they've
assaulted her there or at least that's
too dramatic where they've
made insulted her there insulted her
there uh
but my point would be even in your
self-interest do you not realize that
you are giving ammunition to the real
white supremacists do you not realize
that there are really dangerous people
on the right who are looking for that
exact kind of comment to rationalize
their behavior well if you're trying to
burn something down what makes you think
you're going to be so careful about how
it burns down and i really mean that
look i mean i've i've have interactions
with the right wing
racial supremacists online they're not
very happy with me and it's because i
call them out for the same sort of
behavior that the leftists manifest
which is like
i know i'm not impressed by your
manifestation of group identity uber all
let's say
but i understand that the radical right
wingers are playing the same game as the
radical left winger so you might say
well why would the radical left-wingers
play into their hands i would say well
if you're trying to if you're trying to
burn the whole damn house down
then why not inflame the people who are
most likely to do it and you might think
well no that that's not in anybody's
best interest it's like it's the stated
aim of this ideology right they want to
invert the pi they want to invert the
patriarchy essentially well what's the
patriarchy
well it's the white supremacist
university of toronto
so
who cares if you're handing your
opponent's weapons
you're hoping that it will escalate that
the people on the left as well as the
people on the right escalated
yeah that's the point it is so look at
its power because uh this is the same
thing that happened at evergreen state
and the whole uh justification there was
racism not uh i know when they went
after brett weinstein who was about as i
mean
brett is
he's a bernie he's a bernie supporter
right exactly
well they eat their own last week from
mike paris who was the only colleague of
his that publicly defended him and he
emails me and he says i've been
following the story cut closely and i
just want to reach out and just you know
commiserate with you and wonder is there
anything we can do or talk about
together and i thought
no you're from evergreen state you know
that's a nightmare and i thought we're
not that bad yeah
but but it's the same pattern repeated
it's not about transgendered people and
and their rights and that's just the
victim
sure
no the transgender people as far as i'm
concerned were were like sacrificial
animals on the altar of bill c-16 the
activists have a new group that's
oppressed to wave the flag for to push
forward their ideology and and as i said
the consistent message i've got from
transsexual people is i wish they'd just
shut the hell up and quit putting us out
in in the in the public eye in that guys
because all they're doing is making our
life more difficult it's like well it
doesn't matter we're trying to tear down
the patriarchy who cares if your life is
being made more difficult
it's like you have you don't make an
omelette without breaking a few eggs we
want to keep that in mind okay lori
prepares our students and instructors
for difficult discussions
yeah
probably not we support our teachers in
navigating complex and divisive issues
with care and confidence
a more credible statement i mean
especially given the outcome of this i
just want to take you back to the last
sentence of the previous paragraph
laurier has a clear commitment to
academic freedom and freedom of
expression well that's unequivocal
perfect yes except that they won't adopt
the the chicago principles so for
example and something else to keep in
mind that
i think this is the first time anybody's
talked about this when we were
established in 1973
the wilfred laurier act
says specifically
that this university
will be dedicated to research and
teaching in the spirit of free inquiry
and free expression that is the
establishing act of our universe it's a
charter charter statement and and that
is what it says is our mission
so in fact we are breaking the law
by not standing behind maximum free
expression and max free inquiry because
it it is right in our very founding
principle our very founding charter
and the fact that we are so hesitant
to to just embrace that and say we know
that it's within this contest of ideas
that the best facts come forward and
knowledge is advanced
why are we afraid of that
why are we afraid what's made made
every university a great university
because we're doubtful about the
integrity of the institution like this
this critique that whose claim is that
our institutions our patriarchal
institutions are fundamentally corrupt
and oppressive is sufficiently
what would you say makes people
sufficiently guilty so they're perfectly
willing to
circumvent their adherence to policies
to charter policies like that i just
think that at some point you have to say
this is why you were created
maybe we should get back to this and
maybe i mean maybe there's a someone who
is in the provincial parliament who's
going to say i'm kind of upset that
you've actually rejected the very
founding charter i i would yeah well
there's no one in the current
in the current legislature that would do
that certainly not in the current
government not by any not by not no
chance at all okay
um we support our teachers in navigating
complex and divisive issues with care
and confidence we are leaders in
ensuring our students faculty and staff
have the necessary supports and tools to
help those who have experienced
marginalization and discrimination to
engage fully okay so now you see the
reversal right right away here is and
this happens every time now that a
modern university virtually every time
that a modern university comes out with
a statement in favor of free speech the
next thing they do is is bring in this
competing set of claims like the uh
to help those who have experienced
marginalization and discrimination to
engage fully as soon as the word
marginalization is in there then you
know that that post-modern ethos has has
what has
has
has manifested itself within the with on
the confines of the document properly
grounded academic debate at laurier
occurs every day and encourages critical
thinking and civil discourse yeah
ideas that one finds objectionable
should be challenged and debated the
common good of society depends on the
search for knowledge and its free
expression hey fair enough
free expression in academic university
academic freedom at the university
require accompanying responsibilities
and accountabilities to be met by
members of the university community
well even that statement's not so bad i
mean okay
faculty members have responsibilities
and they should be accountable i think i
think that university should be a civil
place
i think that it should be civil yes
right yes definitely and i think that
there should be tolerance but tolerance
is very different from an embrace an
incomplete embrace of what diversity is
now defined as or equity is defined
tolerance means i disagree but i'm going
to let you speak anyway and that really
is the goal of a university uh so anyway
yeah okay we we will continue to ensure
that we are protected against protecting
against and dealing with hate and
intolerance these have those have no
place in civil society
see
that i'm not so sure about
that hate and intolerance have no place
in civil society the problem with that
is
hate and intolerance is not defined here
that is the problem and and the i keep
hearing
hate speech is not free speech and then
when i ask well what do you mean by hate
speech yes that is the problem well the
other thing too is i'm actually allowed
to hate you
it's okay you might have done something
that makes me hate you but that but
there are limits on what i can do as a
consequence of that hate and that is not
so there's two problems right the first
problem is this is a big one who defines
hate that's a major problem and the
second is
well you don't limit hate you can't
limit hate any more than you can limit
anger or aggression but you can limit
the manner in which people conduct
themselves when they're motivated by
those emotions and let's be clear there
is really a clear definition of hate
when you look at the criminal code under
sections 318 and 319 it says you cannot
advocate physical violence against an
identifiable group i'm totally on board
with that like let's let's be clear
you can't say go and hurt these people i
got that
but that's really clear
where's that definition well i just want
to see well the issue there is something
we discussed earlier is
well then we can gerrymander the
definition of hurt
right well i'm talking physical
advocating physical violence right
physical i throw that physical in there
because the criminal code also does i
think it does it in such a way to say we
can
harm what is harm again harm is
long-term infliction of damage that
compromises your ability to function or
your appearance right
it's a pragmatic definition and it's
grounded in common laws so we actually
have a history of defining it so that's
safe and let's not move away from these
definitions because they're the thing
that allow
us to have conversations that are
uncomfortable but needed
okay good they uh these have no place in
civil society let alone on a university
campus they will not be tolerated at
laurier yes well we see and we saw an
example of that not being tolerated with
the lindsay shepard case
i remain concerned by the way faculty
staff and students involved in aspects
of this situation were targeted with
such vitriol now
now things are starting to get out of
hand i remain concerned by the way
faculty staff and students involved in
aspects of this situation were targeted
with what with such vitriol vitriol
that's acid day
so um is she do you think she's talking
about the tweets that lindsay has
received then is that faculty staff and
students so not just lindsay but i just
wonder is this does this apply
to those who have been advocating free
speech and and i i'm just i'm pointing
it out there i mean all of us who have
come out in favor of maximum free speech
have been subjected to a lot of vitriol
uh both emails and and it's always
anonymous emails it's always from people
who will not say who they are
so but my point would be
i
and unless there was something that
simply said i am threatening your life
i just i delete it that's what i do
because this is what happens i mean i
wish people were civil but they're not
there's no discussing hard issues
without conflict like that's just not
happening the question is how you limit
the conflict and you can't limit it to
none because then people can't have a
conflict they can't solve a problem so
what you do is you you limit it well as
we've limited quite successfully in our
country to date right we use the
definitions of violence that have
prevailed throughout the establishment
of english common law and that works
just fine my concern about that
paragraph is is that she's
cow towing let's say to concerns about
the way that the people who actually
let's say perpetrated this event were
um dealt with by members of the general
public
so
okay member members of the university
community must be supported to work and
study in an environment free of
discrimination and harassment
that's a tougher one and they have my
commitment we will continue to make this
a university priority
yeah that's a sentence that worries me
in an environment free of discrimination
and harassment and they have my comm the
problem is it's so difficult to
distinguish that between real
dispute
you know i mean if you're if you're
committed to a line of argumentation
you've staked your whole your whole life
on it say your whole academic career and
you're engaged in a dispute with someone
else who holds a contrary viewpoint
there's going to be heat and sparks
generated by that exchange there has to
be because otherwise you're not talking
about anything of any importance yeah if
we all agree we don't need free speech i
mean that's the standard that's the
thing right but when i read this line
uh members of the university community
must be supported to work and study in
an environment free of discrimination
and harassment
and and
i just wonder how equally that
idea has been applied at my university
so far because certainly we know that
our president has sent out letters of
support to the lgbtq community which she
was right to do if if they are feeling
harassed i have no problem with that but
at the same time there are official
bodies at our university the women's
center
and other bodies that are under the
auspices of the diversity and equity
office
if i'm correct that are petitioning to
have uh there's a pro-life group on
campus
and and they are petitioning to have
them defunded and shut down
right so so did deborah mcclatchy send
out a letter to all the people who are
supporting lindsay shepard to say well
we're really sorry about all the
harassment this is all that you receive
this is my point
our president is aware that there's a
group on campus
that are
marginalized these are the the pro-life
students and i don't care what your
position is pro-life
or or pro-choice whatever your position
is you bloody will have to admit that
there's at least a debate there is a
debate but and the point i would make is
here truly is a marginalized group of
students who have received no support
from our university none and i know my
president is aware because early on in
this controversy i said and another
matter
is that these students are being
attacked or i'm sorry i don't want to
use hyperbolic language these students
are being harassed and they are being
harassed because they're they're being
threatened with having their funding
removed by official bodies of the
university yeah well this the pro-life
students are real canaries in the coal
mine as far as i'm concerned regardless
of what you think about what they're
doing they represent
diversity
it's ideological diversity
but we're not seeing any reception of
these diverse students
do they are they being included in this
diversity and inclusion no they're being
excluded purposely by actual offices of
my university
so i'm saying yeah
that's standard practice i would say on
campuses across the country it's just
uneven
it's uneven and i think that what
what we need to see
uh is just a policy that applies to all
students and not just those who smell
right or are orthodox
to the social justice organizations or
who are in the what would you call it
acceptable class of victims that's right
okay it bears repeating in the current
context that laurier's support for our
lesbian gay bi trans queer and
two-spirited campus community and
transgender people in particular is
unwavering it isn't obvious that it
bears repeating in the current context
because the issue here fundamentally is
that lindsay shepard was
was subject to an administrative
inquisition despite the fact that she
was 100 percent innocent by the
university's own standards and so it
doesn't bear repeating in the current
context that lori's support for our lbgt
lgbtqts
campus community and pre and transgender
people in particular is unwavering it
actually isn't about them it's not about
them at all it's about the fact that she
got pilloried for doing something that
she was actually right to do
so
i'm not happy with the fact that this
paragraph was inserted into here i think
it's an indication of exactly the kind
of
administrative weakness that allowed
this sort of event to occur to begin
with now this is the theme though
right of the justice warriors is that
this is the victim group they've
repeated over and over that there's been
violence harassment vitriol
everybody's picking up on that the union
president said there was daily
occurrence the president's repeated
she's issued a campus-wide email in
response to the open letter saying uh
we're going to make this a safe campus
uh she's repeating it here so the
validation of their narrative of
victimization emerging from the lindsey
shepherd event without evidence
we we actually send an email to our
faculty uh the union the union president
and we said
we're concerned about this
daily uh violence on campus could you
please supply us with evidence
of this and she wrote back and she said
uh
what did she say well something
as i'm telling everyone in the press no
yeah because it would inflate didn't she
say because it would inflame the
it would explain the situation even
further yes something like that so how
how in the world
providing evidence that something like
that we're members of the union
we are paying
our fees just like everyone else
and we just we wanted substantially some
substantiation to these claims that
there was violence as a daily occurrence
the whole premise is that there's injury
happening and that's why we can't speak
about these things so if they can
establish the violence then maybe we're
sympathetic to the argument that the
speech shouldn't occur but but that's
susceptible to bogus claims if there's
no substantiation
you can't build policy that way yeah
not without getting into the kind of
trouble that's already emerged in light
of recent events we have added measures
to improve campus safety well it is by
no see that that that actually seems to
me to be
the one sentence in this article so far
that's actually a mistake
because by going forward with um
what practices that are going to improve
campus safety then
the president is validating the claims
of the people who claim that this
occurrence produced an unsafe
environment on the campus it's like so
i i think
that that was weak
we will ensure that all students staff
and faculty know exactly what our
commitment to academic freedom and
freedom of expression means in the
classroom that would be good to us in
that end we have established the task
force on freedom of expression to take
input from our community which we should
point out
which won't include lindsay shepard
right because she asked to be part of
that task force in fact i believe that
they offered it to her i'm not exactly
sure about she was some some grad
students nominated her and it was prior
to the revelation being made that it
would be the position would be filled by
the president of the graduate students
association
who
and i think this was poor form
just before that
announcement was made
the president of the graduate students
association
put out a statement where
i'm not sure if it's a he or a she or
i'm not sure of the the uh gender
pronoun used but um
that they were standing 100 percent
behind the trans and lgbtq yeah
and that the fact that they were going
to sit on the on the task force would
indicate that all students would be
represented properly but it's just they
they showed this incredible uh
bias
and and then they said and we're going
to be sitting on this i just don't i
don't know that that does a service to
all the grad students who they represent
all right
look at best practices beyond laurier
hey they could look at chicago that'd be
good and develop a clear tangible and
you never know maybe they will you never
know and develop a clear tangible set of
practical implementable guidelines that
will bring clarity to this issue for our
own classrooms and will have the
potential to serve as best practices for
others well that's exactly what you guys
are recommending that is my commitment
to you well and it's not like the
university of chicago is a lightweight
and it's not just the university of
chicago over 30 universities many of
them ivy league have adopted right the
chicago statements to great effect right
right and so so this is
this is something that has worked yeah
that is working yeah it's clearly
something that should happen in canada
it would be a wonderful thing it would
be a wonderful thing it would be it
would be so wonderful so it's not like
we're trying to institute this policy
that hasn't worked and that hasn't been
been accepted by really prominent
universities in the u.s and it doesn't
it doesn't involve u.s uh law or
legalese it is simply a statement of
philosophy about what we want and which
is maximum free expression and free
inquiry within the bounds of the law
and i just think this task force is
going to be a disaster because
the justice uh advocates aren't
interested in free speech they they want
to forbid certain forms of speech and
it's just a question of which topics and
who's going to control the world well
there might be enough public scrutin
like i don't think interest in wilford
laurie i'm sure that the president would
be real happy if this went away but i
think the probability that it's going to
go away is very low because i think
wilford laurie is now being watched and
being watched by very many people to see
what the genuine outcome of this will be
and i think that even if it was ignored
by the mainstream media which it might
be it's not going to be ignored by
people on youtube and the people who've
been
who've been generating content
associated with lindsay shepard and the
the magnitude of that content online is
absolutely overwhelming i don't know if
the wilford laurier administrators know
because you know people older than 40
usually don't know much about online
media but the amount of
commentary this has been generated this
is generated on youtube is absolutely
beyond belief like it was a major
scandal back to the task force though
and will you've said this in the past
the freedom of expression proponents we
already are the compromised position
because we are saying we want you to be
able to articulate whatever position you
have
we want you to be able like we are the
compromised position we're not saying we
want to shut down anybody whatever your
position is
let's hear it that's that that is where
we are so
we're already in that compromised
position within the boundaries of the
law within the boundary of the law
sections of the uh in in out of respect
for the university and its operations of
course so so we're already saying we
want
all these sides to be able to be heard i
don't understand it's already a pro
diversity of opinions it is it is and
and so
what i have to look at is
many of the colleagues that i have who
are on the left and are hoping for
restriction of free expression
are really to a certain extent
linguistic imperialists
that's exactly why i objected to bill
c-16 i said that i wasn't going to let
the linguistic imperialists take control
over my voice the fact that it happened
to be about transgender pronouns was
well that was just how that problem
manifested itself at that period of time
but that that what did you call them
linguistic imperialist that's exactly
right and and these the the these ideal
ideologues on the radical left who are
so good at neologisms are unbelievably
good at grasping the linguistic
territory i mean the the propagation of
words like cisgendered is a perfect
example of that
so yeah it's just
i don't understand how they can be so
against colonialism and imperialism and
then want to do that
in in the sphere of language put in an
authoritarian structure which can only
be abused
well that's that's part of the weird see
there's this weird marriage between
post-modernism and marxism right which
makes no sense because you actually
can't be a postmodernist and i guess you
can be a
critical thinker and a marxist but you
cannot be a postmodernist at a marxist
at the same time because
the post-modernists hypothetically are
critical of grand narratives right they
don't believe that they that they have
any universal validity of course the
problem with that is that without a
grand narrative you can't act but they
sneak the marxism in through the back
door and then the justification i think
is for these author authoritarian
impositions is that well it doesn't
matter as long as the right people are
being hurt by them and the right people
would be the people who are in positions
of power
now who who have no justification for
being in those positions of power right
because they don't stable solution
but you're making the assumption that
what's being sought after is a stable
solution
and i think that's i think that's a
dangerous assumption because i think
that the
university activists mean exactly what
they say
when they say that we should be flipping
over the patriarchy they've put no
counter proposal forward throughout this
right it's like they don't have a
solution uh they're not even talking
about
a list of forbidden topics and who's to
adjudicate it and what the appeals
process is that's always that's always
done post talk that way you can keep the
level of fear of the high you can keep
adding to the list yes definitely that
because it's way better it's way better
if you it's way better if you want to
exercise power over people to never let
them be sure which policies they are
violating and i think that what happened
to lindsay shepard is an excellent
example of that so it's a it's a
canonical example of that
it's it's the orwellian idea freedom is
the ability to say two plus two equals
four and they want to keep avoiding the
ability to say two plus two is four by
creating new answers and and moving on i
see just went through this whole process
and came up with a statement on free
expression and goes on for paragraphs
and paragraphs and then the last nearly
the last sentence is freedom of
expression does not trump all other
rights
in the university community freedom of
expression can only thrive
constructively when accompanied by other
rights including the equality
rights of equity diversity and inclusion
there you go there you go that's right
and so now you no longer have free
expressions man that's the snake in the
garden right there reading that yeah so
there's there's this but how i mean
those those are so complicated there's
individual rates and group rates there's
positive rights and negative rates and
they're all in this salad
with no guidance as to how you're going
to trade them off uh against each other
it's it's like you say just ad hoc uh as
we go forward we'll we'll well it's so
funny to produce an entire document
talking about freedom of expression and
then to put a sentence like that in is a
codicil it's and by the way also this
it's like wait a second it's not also
this it's that little ad mixture of
poison uh destroys the integrity of the
entire argument and and and to and to
put all those words in there diversity
okay what the hell do you mean by that
exactly
inclusivity that's a word that really uh
that's one i really have a trouble with
because it's very difficult to
understand even what that means and
equity equity is equality of outcome and
so that's an impossible goal to begin
with because it multiplies in difficulty
as you add number of measurement
dimensions right so and that's the
intersectionality problem so to speak
so
all right well with the task force the
interesting thing is will didn't want to
sit on it because
having looked at what had happened i i
suppose it was the experience at ubc
that
well i just saw big arguments happening
with no no possibility of a constructive
outcome
and so but i was more hopeful and i
understand
will's position completely right
yes well it's easy as a faculty member
to get pulled into interminable
administrative duties that have no
positive outcome whatsoever in fact it's
pretty much par for the course well he
makes the i mean
your most compelling argument well two
one look what happened at ubc
and two we're already the compromised
position you mean what what more can you
want
and and i get that but i i have
let my name stand for nomination uh
we'll see this week i guess whether or
not i
i'll i don't know if i'll get voted well
one of the things we should find out and
and publicize is whether any people who
have a strong free speech orientation
will end up on that task force
yeah i mean that that's a that's of
absolutely critical importance well
they'll certainly get their work done
quickly if no one from the free speech
side is on it because they'll just say
right
but maybe they'll have to create a list
of their own about what can't be talked
about
right who knows where that will go one
thing that strikes me though is just the
disregard for history
people who
are marginalized or would be considered
in the marginalized group if we look at
how did they get
the rights that they have today
right how did that happen
it was because of free expression right
actually
the easy case to make for free speech is
left-wing it's like powerful people
don't need their free speech protected
they're powerful they're rich they can
say whatever the hell they want it's
people who are precisely marginalized
and oppressed who need all the
protection of the law of course they
want to weight it against saying yes we
want to have
people without power to have the freedom
of expression but let's make this a
quicker process by making sure those
that have power can't speak whoever
those who have power is right well
that's that's which issue not just well
you know you could say well wouldn't it
be wonderful if those who had unfair
power weren't allowed to speak it's like
well maybe it would be wonderful but who
the hell is going to decide who has
power and who has unfair power like the
devil's in the details there
so the only fair
application of this principle is to let
everybody have equal opportunity
right not equal outcome by the way well
that's the free market solution right
because you can't determine these by
central fiat because it's technically
impossible which is actually something
post-modernists should know because
that's actually one of the logical
consequences of their philosophy right
things are too complicated to decide by
fiat in some sense but
all right is there anything else that
you guys want to say
that that that you've observed as a
consequence of this lindsay shepard
affair or that or that you're hopeful
about or pessimistic about what what
what's the
how do we solve this
just the way we're solving it this is
the way to solve it is to is to
have
i think this is a textbook case of the
utility of free speech
shepard was able to make her case
publicly there's been a huge debate
about it there's been some moves made on
the part of the university that look
positive we've got ample opportunity
everyone has ample opportunity to have
their voice heard you know this video
we're making tonight will probably be
watched by 150 000 people it's like and
we had a perfectly reasonable discussion
you know i think we gave credit where
credit was due with regards to this
document and and are
jointly hopeful that something positive
will come of it and made some pointed
critiques about about what it does
contain and what it doesn't but
we don't want to underestimate the
utility of doing these things it's
useful and i think the fact that you
guys have this little cabel of people at
wilford laurier who are willing to speak
i was shocked when when you wrote that
op-ed and when the toronto star
published it i mean nothing like that
from an academic happened in
relationship to me last year on bill
c-16
we've seen such uniformity of outcry
about this from all the newspapers globe
star
sun which really just
shows you the disconnect between what is
happening in the academy and what is
right it's a disconnect of staggering
magnitude people outside the academy say
how can you believe that
yeah what they've been saying is
really this happened this actually
happened that's the universal response
and and you know the response on the
campuses is well yeah it happened
and we were right i have a solution i
have a solution i mean it's not a
solution but it's
i don't know
i call it an inoculant actually so yes
let's get the laurier statement for
freedom expression at our university and
similar statements at all universities
why the federal government is not tying
funding to this i know that the
conservatives the suggestion that i made
to the conservatives well this is this
is what needs to happen but in addition
to that i think that young people and
and parents of young people need to look
at what's happening and they need to
start educating their their kids at home
and they need to start and i've written
several op-eds where i've said
people ask me what is the solution i say
start watching the videos of jordan
peterson start watching the videos uh
there's a jonathan height jonathan hype
you bet look into the heterodox academy
they know what they're doing who who
definitely are scholars of repute the
they they are moderate in the like
incredibly civil uh there are also some
people outside of academia there's a um
a fantastic youtuber uh
my name is josephine she's a canadian
political science student who is at u of
t
moderate
really well-spoken articulating
classical liberal ideas my name is
josephine okay yeah okay i'll have to
remember so another she's actually been
the reason that i know she knows you she
was at one of your rallies i saw it in a
video there she is in the background um
there another uh young lady uh sorry
woman who is her name is roaming
millennial yeah i know roaming
millennials i've been on her show oh
fantastic yeah yeah yeah you betcha you
bet yeah and she's a tough cookie that
girl
you bet and i would say start watching
these people yeah well the young people
are watching them in droves you know she
has a big following roaming millennials
and i'm grateful for that because in
fact when these students go into the
university classroom if they choose to
go into the arts or the humanities
they're going to go in with knowledge
where they can i realize it's tough to
challenge a professor
but start a facebook group and say hey
did you know that there are other ideas
too do you know that there's an opposite
side to this debate well we should all
we could also encourage parents who
might be listening or students
thinking about going to university who
might be listening to this is that
check to see where the university stands
on free speech and if they dampen down
their support for free speech and for
your inquiry with statements about
diversity inclusivity and equity then go
somewhere else it's a worry
another uh thing and this is just
beginning in canada uh there we have a
society for academic freedom and
scholarship that professors can join if
if
sorry if a professor has joined the
society for academic freedom and
scholarship you can be pretty sure they
are going to be wanting to give you both
sides of the story so that's not a bad
check either yeah
where do they have to do their research
though the students to due diligence
well that's good it'll educate them
right
i mean lindsay shepard definitely got
educated over the last two months
yeah i mean yeah no kidding no kidding
she's got her phd thesis and
communication pretty well demonstrated
there's an auto ethnography for you
yeah i caused an international scandal
by just revealing what had actually
happened
yeah all right
good
my pleasure thank you guys for coming
and also for it's not common
for faculty members well to talk to me
first of all like this certainly not on
record and it's certainly not common for
them to be writing and speaking openly
about such issues so i don't know what
the hell got into you guys it's really
good that's happening at wilford laurier
too we're
we realize we're finished now by being
associated with you yeah yeah yeah i i
said uh earlier good of you to offer
yourself on the sacrificial altar i
you've got to look your kids in the eye
eventually yeah and uh
how are you going to say that you need
to stand up for truth
if you actually don't stand up for truth
that is a problem yeah yeah
all right guys good
thanks a lot